look at the pre Michelangelo history of
the Sistine Chapel and look at the 30
years before Michelangelo actually
arrived on the scene and what the
significance of the building was and why
how Michelangelo ended up painting it
and what the the the the significance of
that was in Italy early in the sixteenth
century we'll have the first line please
this is the man with whom the story
begins a few years before Michelangelo's
birth this is a man named Francesco
della Rovere a who in 1471 was elected
Pope Sixtus the fourth he 1471 is four
years before Michelangelo's birth he
came around in 1475 when Sixtus moved to
Rome to take up the post in 1471 he
discovered a city that that was an
unattractive one we tend to think now of
Rome is a place of beautiful piazzas
fountains churches and so forth it was
very different in the fifteenth century
there were Roma's known as the capital
in D or capital of the world but it
wasn't even that capital of Italy was
this it wasn't really worthy of this
title at all it was smaller than Milan
and smaller than Florence and unlike
Milan and Florence it didn't it wasn't a
city of culture it had very little new
building very few new churches for
example and the buildings that it did
have were in a state of decay obviously
most of them had been built over a
thousand years before during the the
Roman Republic and Roman Empire and
these were being destroyed both by time
and by the Roman stonemasons who knocked
them down not parts of them down to bid
to build a little hovels that the Romans
lived in beside the Tiber it was a
therefore a quite decrepit city it was
also dangerous because of the fact that
the plague arrived roughly every 10
years and wiped out 10 to 20 percent of
the population it also flooded and it
was prone every summer to malaria it was
a very swampy area and mosquitoes bred
and and was renowned throughout Italy
for its bad air it was also riven by
factional strife there were the feudal
barons competing with one another for
control of Rome at this time it was the
Colonna and Orsini families and so they
had essentially carved up the cities
they acted as in a sense as warlords who
controlled their various sectors of the
city with their armed bands and so it
was very different from a city like
Florence which obviously had
Brunelleschi working in it beautifying
with churches and of course with a
Cathedral ascent the dome of the
cathedral as santa maria del fiore rome
had nothing on that scale that had been
built in the past thousand years
Sixtus decided he was going to do
something about all of this and try to
make Rome a more worthy seat for the
Roman Catholic Church this is an image
of Rome a couple of decades after he
arrived on the scene you can see a
number of features this is old st.
Peter's which was the Constantinian
Basilica built in the 4th century and
right next to it of the Vatican Palace
another bit of a papal residence the
Palazzo del Belvedere up on the hill
above Rome and you can see the Tiber
flowing through it a couple of bridges
over it including the Ponte Santangelo
which leads to this fortress the Castel
Sant'Angelo other a few other landmark
marks you might recognize this is the
colosseum here none of this is to scale
obviously and you can see the wall
encircling Rome at this time Sixtus then
began in the 1470s a campaign of
beautification he built he started he
either built or had rebuilt a number of
new churches roads he also widened roads
he founded the Vatican Library to try to
make Rome a site of culture and a place
to which scholars would flock and become
part of the papal Court but the most
important foundation of his and what his
reign now is of course most known for is
the the building he had constructed
between old st. Peter's in the Vatican
Palace
since the 13th century a small chapel
had stood there was known as the old
chapel and it served as the place where
the Pope's traditionally celebrated Mass
and vitally it also served as the place
where after the death of a pope the
Cardinals would gather and hold their
conclaves
to elect a new pope as that was quite an
important structure for the Vatican and
for the Catholic Church as a whole
unfortunately by the 1400s the church
had begun to lean a number of feet out
of true I'm you're probably aware of the
way in which many early Christian
churches and churches in the Middle Ages
were built on the sites where Saints
were martyred and it's an unfortunate
fact that Saints had a tendency to be
martyred on very marshy ground the vet
Hall Vatican Complex is no no exception
to this rule that old st. Peters is
built on the site where it's felt that
st. Peter was martyred in 67 ad several
hundred years later constantine moved
his body from the catacombs where he'd
been buried and interred them on the
site and then built old st. peter's over
it old st. peter's by the 1400s was also
in a bad structural state situation
we'll come back to shortly but this
small chapel the old chapel is also
leaning and so Sixtus took a sort of
typically robust decision and decided
that what he would do would be to knock
this Chapel down and begin constructing
a new one in order to do this he hired a
Florentine architect the Florentines
sort of due to Brunelleschi's
preeminence early and earlier in the
century were known as some of the best
architects in Italy and so Sixtus with
his long arm reached out and plucked the
Florentine architect named bacio pant le
brought him to Rome and commissioned him
to build a new chapel upon telle in some
ways was a curious choice for building a
church he had trained under a man named
French on a
another Florentine the franchisees claim
to fame was that he invented a
Battlement that could supposedly with
withstand any cannonball and he built
his what he did was to build
fortifications castles city walls and so
forth bacio Pontellier followed him into
this trade and became one of the chief
military architects in the middle
decades of the 15th century and he built
what was the most advanced fortress of
the day at Ostia on the at the mouth of
the Tiber on the coast near Rome and so
given all of this it does seem somewhat
curious that Sixtus wanted him to build
the Sistine Chapel but if we see the
Sistine Chapel here and we can see we
can I think appreciate the contribution
of bocce upon telly
it's a very robust structure it doesn't
necessarily look like a chapel it is the
walls at the base of it are three meters
thick so in order to repel any cannon
ball that might come its way there are
also it's a bit difficult to see in the
photograph but there are arrow slits
along these points here where archers
could conceal themselves and fire
flaming arrows at anyone trying to
attack the Vatican and any of these
invaders who escape the flaming errors
flaming arrows then face the danger of
boiling oil that could be poured on them
from apertures around the battlements at
this point and so pond telly was clearly
creating a structure that had a military
as well as a an ecclesiastical function
and it's we might ask why he was doing
this and why Sixtus wanted him to do it
that we have no further back to look
than 1471 when Sixtus had his coronation
in Rome when you had your coronation as
a pope you would move from the Vatican
area across the the entire city to the
the east side where the you were crowned
in san giovanni Lata know which
the Mother Church of the Roman Catholic
religion but unfortunately for Sixtus on
his way across Rome he was attacked and
stoned by the Roman mob which was not a
Roman mobs frequently responded to
Pope's in this in this less than cordial
fashion
there was a strong Republican element in
Rome which obviously stretched back as
far as the ancient Roman Republic and
the Roman the Roman mob as well as the
Roman barons didn't take kindly to the
fact that usually a foreigner is an
Italian from outside of Rome would come
into the city every 10 years or so
assume the position of Pope and hold
secular power over them because of
course at this time
Pope's weren't simply spiritual leaders
they also had temporal authority and the
Pope's around this period had seconds
had temporal power over probably about a
million people in Rome but also in the
countryside around and in cities such as
Bologna and Perugia and so the Pope's in
some ways were besieged in they were in
hostile territory in the Vatican and so
I think six this was very conscious that
he needed to protect himself and perhaps
the Cardinals as well the precariousness
of being a pope is was brought home to
Sixtus again in the fourteen 70s shortly
after he assumed power when he went to
war as popes often did in those days
because they had to protect their
interests their economic interests in
the area outside of Rome and his battle
in the fourteen 70s was with this man
whom you might recognize Lorenzo de
Medici Lorenzo the Magnificent who was
the leader of Florence at this time
Lorenzo and Sixtus came to blows over
the city-state of INLA on which both of
them wanted to control it was on the
road to Venice and whoever controlled
amela controlled that trade route six
dis altom utley gained power of imlah
installed his nephew
possibly I should put nephew in
quotation marks because the the Pope's
were notorious for all of the nephews
that they had and in certain cases these
were the sons in six this is case this
may have been true in a number of cases
the battle broke out and between Lorenzo
and Sixtus in after the event there is
the patsy conspiracy where the Sixtus
tried to assassinate Lorenzo in the
cathedral of santa maria del fiore
during mass war broke out and continued
for a couple of years all this while the
Sistine Chapel was being built in the
throat throughout the 1470s and when the
chapel was finally finished in 1480 the
war was finished as well and as a kind
of peace offering Lorenzo de Medici sent
from Florence to Rome a team of frescoes
Florentine frescoes of course being the
most renowned in Italy at this time and
these men were almost a kind of peace
offering from Lorenzo to Sixtus because
obviously once the chapel is finished it
needs to be decorated with of frescoes
tapestries sculptures and so forth the
so this artistic delegation or this
peace offering leaves Florence in
roundabout 1480 and goes south to Rome
and at this time Michelangelo is five
years old and I think as he grew up in
the over the next decade he would have
been well aware of this commission which
was obviously an extremely prestigious
one partly because he knew Lorenzo it
became to know the Renzo de Medici very
well and also he came to know the team
of artists who went to Rome there are a
generation older than him
but he came to know them in some cases
I'm going to competition against them
they were led by a man who wasn't
actually a Florentine Pietro Perugino
who came as his name suggests from
Perugia but he had worked in Florence
from
among various other Italian cities for
many years he was reaching the height of
his powers at this point and he led a
team that included other artists with
whom I'm sure you're familiar such as
Sandro Botticelli who was beginning to
make his name at this point
Cosimo Roselli who is a member of a
large and well-known Florentine family
of artists and also possibly most
interestingly Domenico Gillan died oh
when this time was in his early 30s and
was beginning to make his name in
Florence and abroad and within a few
years by 1488 so a few years after he
goes to Rome will become Michelangelo's
master Michelangelo goes into Gilland da
studio round about 15 of 1487 1488 so
michelangelo certainly would have heard
stories of this commission and he's been
going to Rome to work for the Pope in
the Sistine Chapel as Petter Geno's team
worked on the walls of the Sistine
Chapel I mean what their remit was to
was to paint the walls of the chapel
with on one side images from the life of
Christ on the other images from the life
of Moses all the while that this was
going on
it took them about 18 months to two
years to do it the vault was also being
painted by a man named pure Matteo
d'emilia he wasn't from Florence he was
from the Bologna area and he wasn't as
well known as para Gino and his team and
I think this is interesting because the
vaults of chapels certainly at this time
were not as prestigious as as the walls
it was the walls of a chapel that you
frescoed and and that were frescoed and
people paid the most attention to
because obviously looking at a vault is
much more difficult than looking at a
wall Pierre what Pierre Madero mainly
event did was to fresco a very basic
design on the vault what he did was to
put a essentially create an image of
heaven or of a story sky a blue field
that was dotted with
stars very common image in Christian art
that many of you might have seen in
various churches in Rome and Venice
especially the despite the fact that
this team I've been describing was
reaching their height of their the
height of their powers and becoming
increasingly well-known in Florence and
abroad none of them is really thought to
have excelled himself but at this it's
not Botticelli's best work nor Gillan
diyos nevertheless Perugino did create
what is one of his masterpieces and one
of the best frescoes of the 15th century
a work of art that's generally known as
the giving of the keys to Saint Peter
which is interesting for a number of
reasons
beyond the the sort of beautiful
perspective seen that he's created it
illustrates the scene from the Gospel of
st. Matthew where Christ confers
priestly powers on st. Peter and in
effect makes him the first Pope Peter of
courses is Pope number one in the
history of the church and Christ prisons
him Peter or Rock and says upon this
rock I will build my church and I give
you the keys to the kingdom of heaven
and that's the scene that we obviously
see right here the kneeling st. Peter
receiving the keys to the kingdom of
heaven the keys which are the symbol of
the papacy today from Christ through a
number of interesting little features in
it Perugino in a sort of time-honored
fashion his cream included his
self-portrait but he's also included a
portrait of boccie up on tele the man
who built the Sistine Chapel and
Giovanni de Dolce the the master mason
in charge of the building the actual
building work it's a piece of papal
propaganda in many ways as were other
ones on the walls of the Sistine Chapel
this image of the the founding moment of
the papacy features st. Peter in the
blue and gold livery in blue and gold
livery which just happened to be the
colors of the della Rovere a clan from
which Sixtus the fourth comes and so the
link between 60
and Peter has made very clearly Sixtus
whose authority as Pope obviously is
under threat at certain points in his
career as is any Pope's at this time
Sixtus wants to emphasize that he is the
the the latest in this apostolic
succession and it's interesting that
this fresco becomes very famous in Rome
at this time
Michelangelo certainly would have known
of it from his trips to Rome in the
1490s and when he finally comes to paint
in the Sistine Chapel the number of
decades later he says that he wants to
outdo what's gone before and so he wants
to Trump perigee no Gil and io
Botticelli and Cosimo Roselli this older
generation of Florentine artists and so
he's clearly competing with Perugino and
those that his work is going to be
compared with para Geno's masterpiece
and incidentally I discuss it in the
book but I won't have time tonight
with Michelangelo had a very difficult
relationship with Perugino
as he did with many other artists and at
one point the two of them were hauled
before the magistrates in Florence after
their dispute one of their disputes got
out of hand and were asked to explain
themselves the reputation of para ninos
fresco spread into the College of
Cardinals and it held a certain status
for them in the last decades and of the
fifteenth century in the early decades
of the 16th with I've said that the
Sistine Chapel was the place that the
Cardinals meant to hold their conclaves
to elect a new pope as obviously it
still is today when the Cardinals do
this the Conclave may last for a week
and so they have beds set up in the
Sistine Chapel with little dividers
between them the the Sistine Chapel in
these occasions which sort of comes to
resemble a hospital ward with the
Cardinals ranged round the
edge of it and so obviously when they're
in these little cells as they're called
where they eat sleep and scheme they're
beneath the wolf directly beneath the
wall frescoes and it soon came to be
known that whoever had the lucky sent
the cell beneath perigee knows giving of
the keys to st. Peter would win the
papacy this was possibly because of this
subject matter of the fresco the fact
that it shows the the founding moment of
the papacy and if I can fast forward
some twenty years now a nephew of Sixtus
the fourth who died in 1484 Cardinal
name Giuliano della Rovere II is a
powerful Cardinal in Rome who's up for
the papacy and lo and behold he gets the
lucky cell beneath Peres Gino's giving
of the keys to st. Peter he may well
have paid a bribe in order to get this
cell because he certainly paid bribes to
all of the Cardinals to have them elect
him and so he was duly elected pope
julius ii on november the 1st 1503 and
came to the throne of st. Peter at this
point one of the most notorious popes in
the history of the church he what well
when he was elected Pope many people
outside the College of Cardinals were
very surprised because they knew that he
was either hated or feared or both by
all of the Cardinals but nevertheless he
managed to persuade the wealthiest men
in Rome
Agostino qiji a banker from Siena to
loan him money and he managed to bribe
enough Cardinals to win the crown he be
cussed the character of Julius in the
book I mean he's a very dominant
personality he's known as Papa Terry
ballet on the terrifying or awesome Pope
which is an interesting and impressive
epithet to have attained in the early
1500s when you consider that the Pope
one of his predecessors the Pope who
died in 1500
three was Alexander the sixth who was
Rodrigo Borgia so even in the age of
Rodrigo Borgia the father of Cesare and
Lucrezia Giuliano della Rovere became
known as the terrifying or awesome Pope
he was also known as the warrior pope
for reasons that I'll come to presently
when Julius of whom I have a picture
here painting by Raphael when Julius
came to the throne in 1503 he still had
many of the problems that his uncle
experienced the finances of the papacy
lens of the the the Pope's that had been
gobbled up by various predatory
neighbors and so forth but very close
even closer to home he had a problem
with the Sistine Chapel Sistine
obviously standing for Sixtus and this
monument to his uncle to whom he owed
very much in his career was now going
the way of the old chapel it had
replaced a couple of decades earlier
because bocce open tele may have known a
lot about repelling cannonballs and and
pouring boiling oil on potential
assailants but he didn't know much about
soil mechanics and so the the phone the
Sistine Chapel was built on very poor
foundations and and only some 20 odd
years after its completion the south
wall had begun to lean necessitating the
closing of the chapel in 1504 and the
introduction of an architect a man named
Giuliano Sangalo who was incidentally
one of Michelangelo's mentors here
Michelangelo didn't get on with very
many artists in in Florence but sang
Gallo was so so someone that he saw as
his protector and mentor sang Gallo was
a generation older than him what's sang
Gallo proceeded to do in the summer of
1504 was to insert a series of iron tie
bars into the the vaults of the chapel
you know
order to arrest the movement of the
south wall and this did temporarily work
further action had to be taken later in
the century of its Sangalo seems to have
solved it for the time being however the
solution of this problem created another
one because they cracks in the vault as
well as the gouging into the masonry of
the vault to the place the iron tie bars
meant that the beautiful fresco done by
pyramid Amalia this image of heaven
suddenly had unattractive bolts of
lightning streaking through it and so
Julius decided that he he had to take
action
to beautify it because he really did see
it as the monument to his beloved uncle
um and of course um he believed that he
knew exactly the man for the job of
fresco in the chapel and this men was
Michelangelo who came to Rome on the
command of Julius early in 1505 several
months after the chapel opened the
chapel was reopened in the autumn of
1504
Michelangelo at this time was thirty
thirty-one ruff roughly thirty one
thirty
I'm sorry thirty years old and was known
he had an Italy wide if not a European
wide reputation but his reputation was
not in fresco who was in sculpture he
was known primarily for the Pieta which
he had finished round about fifteen
hundred for the tomb of a French
Cardinal which and that the Pieta was at
this time displayed in all st. Peter's
he also was known for the David which
was carved in Florence over a number of
years and unveiled in September 1504 in
front of the Palazzo Vecchio at almost
exactly the same time that the Sistine
Chapel was reopening and so Michelangelo
having finished the David appeared to
Julius to be free to come to Rome and
enter his service the
is curious however given Michelangelo's
reputation as a sculptor why Julius
wanted him to fresco the vault of the
Sistine Chapel
fresco was something that Michelangelo
would have learned the rudiments of in
Gilliland IRAs workshop he entered the
workshop when he was probably 12 or 13
years old stayed for a couple of years
during which time he did work on what is
gear Linda's masterpiece in Santa Maria
Novella scenes from the life of John the
Baptist it is believed that Michelangelo
probably as a 14 year old was on the
scaffold helping Ghirlandaio along with
probably 10 to 15 other assistants and
apprentices Michelangelo and Gilliland
diode didn't get on very well according
to Michelangelo who was later to claim
he didn't learn anything from him which
is I think a nun charitable comment and
his part because his draftsmanship
certainly owed everything to Gil and I
owe the he in any case he left Gilliland
I was serviced in about 1492 enter the
the service of Lorenzo de Medici and
from that point onward almost
exclusively he worked in sculpture he
did a number of small paintings and he
also started a fresco which he didn't
which I discuss in the book which he
never actually got around to painting
after events overtook him but by 1505
1506 when the Pope is beginning to think
that Michelangelo is the man for the job
he hasn't worked in the the medium in
any real capacity in almost 20 years and
so he does seem like something of a
strange choice and fresco that it would
have been an intimidating Commission
because of the fact that fresco was
known as the most difficult and even
dangerous of all painting techniques it
was said that anyone could succeed at
tempera painting painting an altarpiece
for example using tempera paint which
was
mixing your paints with a fixative such
as an animal glue fresco was a very
different style of painting and it was
said that only the very best artists
ever succeeded added and all of the
great reputations in Italian art were
made in fresco Chima by Giotto Masaccio
masolino
para della Francesca all of the big
names were fresco it's almost first and
foremost the I'm sure many of you know
the technique and and many of the steps
involved in it obviously if you wanted a
wall or a vault fresco and it wasn't
simply a matter of drawing with a piece
of chalk or charcoal on the wall of the
vault and then painting by numbers on
the dry plaster or dry stone it was a
much different process that in in
entailed numerous preparatory steps and
the word fresco means fresh and that
indicates how fresco the fresco has
worked on wet plaster fresh or wet
plaster and obviously plaster would only
stay wet for a number of hours maybe 8
to 12 hours and so you could only work
on a very confined space each day that's
when the fresco was did is every morning
he hired a plasterer to lay a field of
maybe 10 square feet or if he felt very
ambitious 20 square feet and he would
begin to paint he would apply his
cartoon which involved various
procedures that I discuss in the book
and then really paint against the clock
trying to finish his work before the
plaster dried and his pigments would no
longer fix and so the beauty of this
when it worked was that your pigments
were locked in the plaster and and
theoretically would be there for all
time they essentially became part of the
stone it was fraught with all sorts of
possibilities for mishap there are many
stories of what could go wrong in fresco
painting and so you would have been very
intimidating for Michelangelo to have
been
told what you have to do is present is
paint a fresco and not just any fresco a
fresco on a vault which was obviously
going to create its own problems and a
fresco there was 12,000 square feet the
the largest fresco of the 15th century
was Gilliland Iowa's fresco in Santa
Maria Novella and it was 6,000 square
feet and so Michelangelo was suddenly
confronted with painting something
double that size and what it's curious
to us then why Julius did this it seems
illogical Julius was a great patron of
the Arts like his uncle and he would
have known Michelangelo's capabilities
he also could have with his papal muscle
have convinced any other painter in
Italy to come to Roman volton paint the
vault of the Sistine Chapel and so it is
curious why he wanted Michelangelo
it wasn't however a curious -
Michelangelo he thought he knew exactly
why Julius had selected him or rather
why Julius was being coached so to
select him aboard a commission he
believed that there was a conspiracy if
afoot in Rome a dark plot that involved
this man the papal architect Donato
Bramante Bramante at exactly this time
in 1505 began competing for the
Commission to rebuild st. Peter's
Cathedral the Basilica Saint Peters and
Bramante was a very ambitious man very
talented but also very ambitious then a
his name was actually Donato D'Angelo
but he was known as Bramante
which means ravenous and that's an apt
an apt epithet for someone who had his
supposedly ravenous sexual appetites but
also his overweening ambition
probably a few architects had ever
wanted to build on the scale that
Bramante wanted to build on and so he
finally got his dream job which was
the reconstruction of st. Peter's which
was going to be the largest church in
Christendom Michelangelo and Bramante
didn't see eye to eye Michelangelo as
I've said was a very suspicious person
and he was particularly suspicious of
other artists especially other talented
artists such as Bramante and he believed
that Bramante had it in for him
the crux of the problem is what as
Michelangelo saw in as that was that he
was originally going to be commissioned
to carve the tomb of julius ii when you
became pope much like a fit when you
became Pharaoh he would begin building
the monument that would would glorify
you to all posterity and so very shortly
after Julius came to power he brought
Michelangelo to Rome and and decided
that he would have him carve his tomb
and it wasn't just going to be any tomb
it was going to be the largest tomb
built for anyone since the days of the
Roman emperors it was going to be really
essentially as large as a house some 50
feet high and it was going to comprise
40 or 50 life-sized or over life-size
statues and of course it was going to be
crowned by a magnificent 15-foot high
statue of Pope Julius himself
Michelangelo was only too happy to take
this commission when Julius gave it to
him early in 1505 and he rushed away to
Carrara where the best marble was to be
found
began quarrying it and then shipped a
hundred tons of marble to Rome in order
to begin building it unfortunately for
him by the time he returned to Rome
in 1506 the situation had changed
slightly because during the year that he
was away Bramante had been given the
commission for st. Peter's and had in
fact defeated Giuliano de san Gallo for
the for the commission the two of them
had been competing each of them
submitted a plan
sangala was probably the favorite
because he would had hitherto been
Julia's favorite architect and had built
when Julius was a cardinal Sant Gallo
had built a number of palaces for him
throughout Italy nevertheless the Pope
decided that he wanted Bramante's design
and so this was a kind of defeat for the
Florentine artists in Rome sang Gallo
who is at this time has around 60 years
old was in effect leader of a Florentine
faction of artists at the papal court if
you were a young artist and you came to
Rome at this time he sort of fell into
your a group that was based on kinship
and the town that you came from as a
Michelangelo obviously was one of the
Florentines Bramante who came from
Urbino a dukedom to the east of florence
and was that set himself up as the
leader of a number of artists from other
places in italy mainly the north of
italy and so suddenly in 1505 Bramante's
faction had the upper hand over the
Florentines and michelangelo was
convinced that Bramante was responsible
for telling the pope that he shouldn't
have his tomb built in his own lifetime
and that he should you know he should
wait until after he was dead and have it
built he supposedly told Julie so it's
bad luck to have you you're a tombstone
built in your own lifetime
Julie's supposedly agreed and told
Michelangelo that he wasn't going to
proceed with it which was a devastating
blow to Michelangelo who thought who
desperately wanted to work on this
gargantuan structure and immediately as
the Commission for the tomb was taken
away the Sistine Chapel project was was
mooted Bramante had supposedly reasoned
according to what michelangelo told
everyone who would listen that if
Michelangelo had been allowed to carve
the tomb of Julie's he his reputation
across Europe would have been
unassailable as is essentially the
world's greatest artist suppose
Bramante didn't want to be eclipsed by
the genius of Michelangelo and so he
scuppered the plan for the tomb and
convinced julius to give him a
commission at which he couldn't possibly
succeed the painting of the Sistine
Chapel and he Bramante in Michelangelo's
words had read the reasons that
Michelangelo would either tackle the
commission or attempted tackle it and
fail an attempt and thereby destroy his
reputation and sort of leave Rome in
disgrace or he would refuse the
Commission and flee from Rome and just
leave Rome and go elsewhere which is in
effect what happened because in April of
1506 on the eve not coincidentally of
the laying of the foundation stone of
new st. Peter's Michelangelo got on his
horse in the dead of night and rode
through the gates of Rome and headed
north to Florence pursued by the papal
agents who had their orders once they'd
learned he'd left to bring him back to
Rome what follows then is it two years
ago in which Michelangelo is fleeing
from the Pope and refusing to return and
ultimately given the kind of test of
loyalty from the Pope in episode that I
discuss in the book where he's given a
smaller Commission from the Pope almost
to prove his loyalty and he believes
that if he completes this this statue
he'll be allowed to carve the tomb for
the Pope and all will be forgiven
but initially what happened is that he
when he fled from Rome he refused to
return even though the Pope at this time
published a number of papers ordering
him to return but he flatly refused for
the first few months at least and it's
an interesting fact that he that we have
this an artist a mere artist who in this
time is really regarded as nothing more
than an artisan was was refusing to obey
a pope and Julius was not a man
you wish to cross and finally he went
back and met the Pope and tried to
reconcile with him on orders from Peru
so Turini who was the leader of the
Florentine Republic at this time and so
dharini wrote to him wrote wrote to
Michelangelo in a letter that still
exists saying make up your mind to go
back to Rome because we will not be
dragged into a war over you because
Julius of course is known as the warrior
Pope and was continually strapping on
his saber and mounting his horse and
heading off to subdue Bologna for
example or Perugia and I think so
Dharini was worried that that Julius and
his Swiss mercenaries would arrive at
the gates of Florence and besieged the
city until it surrendered Michelangelo
to him so it's only at that point then
the Michelangelo enters re-enters the
service of the Pope
a year later he finally goes back to
Rome and thinks that he's going to have
the commission that he wants his plan is
he's running memos to himself that he
needs money to carve the tomb but of
course he's going to be sorely sorely
disappointed because that Commission is
not forthcoming he's going to have to
paint the fresco he sort of resigns
himself to that destiny in the spring of
1508 however in those two years he's
been away from Rome the situation has
changed slightly and appears to be
stacked against him even more if I could
point out a few features of the Vatican
area this is obviously taken from the
dome of st. Peters we can see the
Sistine Chapel here right beside st.
Peters and here's the Vatican Palace and
the annex to it the Cortile the
Belvedere a that Bramante was building
at this time the the Sistine Chapel was
in very close proximity to the Vatican
Palace and the apartments in which all
the popes traditionally lived Julius was
no exception in 1503 he moved into the
Vatican and into the second floor the
only problem for him
was that this suite of apartments had
been occupied until 1503 by Rodrigo
Borgia and his entourage and of course
they're all the stories of the Borgia
decadence in the in the Vatican at this
time twenty five mistresses a night
being twenty five prostitutes a night
being shipped into the Vatican to
pleasure Rodrigo in the Cardinals the
night of the famous night of the
courtesans when all of the courtesans in
Rome were entertained and entertained in
there
Julius wasn't necessarily bothered by
that by the supposing Borgia debauchery
because he was no mean de vache himself
in his younger days he'd fathered a
number of children whom he openly
acknowledged and he'd also contracted
syphilis at some point and was suffering
the effects of it during this period now
what bothered him really were was
Rodrigo's taste in interior decoration
Rodrigo had hired a man named Pinter
Akio a very prolific fresco was to paint
in the chapel painter Akio was known in
tariqas name means rich painter and it
sort of indicates the way in which he
operated with very brilliant colors it
wasn't really that either that bothered
Julius because he used painter Akio in
some of his own commissions what
troubled him were the the the images of
the Borgia family everywhere in the
frescoes so for example when you see st.
Catherine of Siena in one of the
frescoes in what are now called the
Borgia apartments it's actually the
crate see a Borgia the the the Borgia
coat of arms could be seen above every
door the Borgia bull and so forth so it
was suggested to Julius that what he
could do would be to simply take a
hammer to the the walls and knock the
fresco out but to his credit he said
this wouldn't be proper and what he
would do would be to move up a level
onto the third floor of the Vatican and
occupy rooms there but of course once
you do that you anytime you move house
you have to bring in the decorators and
you have to have everything painted
and so what he did in 1508 was to have
Bramante this time the people architect
and in charge of all people building
bring together a team of painters to
fresco that the rooms on the third floor
and Bramante brought together eight the
highest powered team of fresco ists seen
in Rome since Perugino
had painted the walls of the Sistine
Chapel and in fact Perugino
was one of the painters hired by
Bramante to fresco in the chapel there
were a number of other very experienced
painters as well men who had vastly more
experience than Michelangelo did all of
them were assembling at exactly the same
time Michelangelo and his team were
assembling literally next door in the
Sistine Chapel and Michelangelo began
painting probably in October of 1508 and
exactly the time Perugino and company
did and within a month or two another
artist appeared on the scene the new Boy
Wonder of Italian painting the protege
of Bramante a man who may even have been
a kinsman of Bramante that of course is
Raphael Raphael came from Bramante's
hometown of Urbino and it was rumored
that the two of them were related in
some way Raphael at this time has just
begin to make his name in Florence um he
worked in Florence for the previous four
years on various altar pieces various
private commissions for individuals
portraits and so forth and was really
beginning to make his reputation but he
was a very ambitious young man and
wanted knew that in order to truly make
his name he had to have a large fresco
commissioned and so the offer came from
Bramante possibly from Perugino with
whom he'd worked before possibly from
julie's himself whose relatives had used
Raphael in a commission a few years
earlier in any case Raphael arrived in
Rome attic virtually the same time
Michelangelo began painting and within a
few months months of being in Rome
actually took over the Commission in the
Vatican apartments because so impressed
with Julius with Raphael's work that he
dismissed Perugino and the rest of the
team and gave Raphael overall control of
the work in the Vatican and so by 1509
Raphael and Michelangelo were truly in
competition with one another and so one
of the things I wanted to do in the book
one of the main things was to look at
the competition between these two young
artists who were really reaching the
height of their powers and in the book I
tell that the way in which Raphael was
influenced by Michelangelo and
Michelangelo is very paranoid attitude
towards towards Raphael
I think I'll conclude with an anecdote
about the two of them that I think says
something about each of their characters
Raphael was raised in Urbino as the the
son of the court painter to the Duke
Duke of Urbino and he behaved
accordingly he was a very sociable young
man he had many friends many young
apprentices came to Rome explicitly to
work for him and it was said that he
lived like a prince with his court he
was a very handsome young man very
generous with his time and money and
whenever he went anywhere he was always
trailed by his entourage people who
worked with him people who were his
friends Michelangelo could also be
sociable he had a kind of sarcastic wit
that was appreciated in in certain
circles and his own kind of grim notions
of what constituted jokes nevertheless
he was very much a loner
the solitary figure was liked his own
company above everyone else's and he
although he assembled a team of workers
with to labor with him side by side on
the Sistine scaffold scaffold he spent
much of his time alone brooding over
various insults against him and ways had
been slighted and ways in which Julius
wasn't appreciating his town
and so forth the story goes then that
the two men met in the Piazza San Pietro
as they were bound to do working in such
close proximity
even though Michelangelo tried to evade
Raphael or tried to keep himself oh and
especially his fresco and his drawings
away from Raphael's eyes then the two
men were bound to me as they did this
afternoon in the Piazza San Pietro
Raphael of course with his entourage
Michelangelo of course alone and
Michelangelo in his usual sarcastic way
is said to have snarled at Raphael
you with your band like a Bravo
insinuating that Raphael was a kind of
young tuff followed by there's this band
of hooligans and Raphael responded and
you alone like the hangman which I think
says something not only about the way
Raphael perceived Michelangelo but about
the way the people in Rome and probably
Florence's well perceived him as a kind
of as a solitary taciturn outsider who
is possibly even a somewhat sinister
figure and the rut Raphael
when Raphael's other great tribute to
Michelangelo or comment to Michelangelo
comes in the Vatican apartments where he
paints Michelangelo's portrait after
having seen the this imagery of the
Sistine Chapel his art changed
dramatically at that point partway
through the painting of the Vatican
apartments when Michelangelo's worst
fear was realized
and Raphael got into the Sistine Chapel
to see his work and so Raphael's work
and indeed the the art of every other
artist working in Italy and and
ultimately in Europe changed in seeing
the Sistine Chapel
I think I'll conclude at that point dr.
King
[Music]
we're an extremely informative
presentation and we will see you all out
of the book signing thank you for coming
[Applause]
Ross King is author of ex libris and his
latest Michelangelo and the Pope ceiling